[Music]
welcome everyone to the first ever
live game sport after dark podcast
which happens to be the 150th episode of
gamespot after dark
as always we like to make it convoluted
we like to make it different but yeah we
are streaming on twitch.tv so if you
listen if you're listening to this on
podcast services
you're [ __ ] up
if you are listening to this later on
get your [ __ ] together be here live
let's go
i'm your host tomorrow zayn joined by on
my left the podfather jake decker so i
was gonna get a steak to eat during this
episode
but you didn't but i didn't because i
saw how
i saw how small this room was and i was
like it's gonna smell like steak for a
very long time also eating steak to go
doesn't seem like a good plan no
interestingly the the pendulum has
really swung on eating on a podcast
though
is it an asmr thing no it's it's people
have become used to streamers streaming
tonight
this is this is all john luke's making
so if something goes incredibly well you
can uh thank you luke for that if it
breaks you can blame jean lucas
also you're you're live switching with a
stream deck not steam deck i am yeah
which i keep calling it which is very
cool if it was live switching with the
steam deck that'd be very impressive on
this the day of the steam summer sale
we also have jordan remain to my right
what up what up and for the first time i
think this is a podcast of many first
we've got five people we're also joined
by lucy james hi
how are you doing i'm all right yeah
come in to the office it's a lovely day
in san francisco
i'm here with my buds
it's thursday
all right i'm just going to keep talking
i don't know i
am recovering from coronavirus he has
tested negatives multiple times
oh my god we went to see uh jake's new
apartment and tom just went like don't
worry i tested positive i mean negative
the look of terry lisa's eyes and jake's
jake's just complete ambivalence because
he has like i already had anything don't
give a [ __ ] he's like
wait this weekend i can't be sick no so
i but i do still have a cough so if you
see me suddenly turning away to cough
that's because i just i'm i'm about that
coughing life now but i promise you i am
good
um as as with most twitch um productions
we are monitoring the chat so if you
have questions chuck them in the chat
and we will uh just absolutely ignore
most of them but we'll answer the good
ones
i'm going to try to round them up and
throw them in our outline yeah so we can
uh hopefully answer them yeah we've
already got a bunch of people friendly
faces in in the chat we got batman yes
batman is alive and he's in our chat
um
we've got some sloppy steak talk which
is uh maria's in there
uh chris pereira's in there chris prayer
with uh what does corey barlog know
oh my god matt padgett is in there
unfortunately
um tri-lands is in here
uh i think that's chris hayner's in
there as well yeah
so sorry about moobot yeah an egregious
mod that we
can't control
a lot of things going on but yeah
we will be keeping an eye on that we're
probably gonna go roughly two hours um
which is a little longer than our usual
podcast because we figured if we're
gonna make a big song and dance of
getting everyone here live we will go
for a little longer
um this is a kind of like test run so
things will break and we'll probably
move
our
live streams in the future to an another
timing mainly because we don't want to
force people to
um
choose between us and uh the beloved
voicemail dump truck on on giant between
mom and dad yeah especially since
there's a good chance that
at least lucy and i will be on the
voicemail dump truck in the future
i'll only be on if paul right gets on i
think you guys should just do them at
the same time at the same time yeah i've
just run back i've done multiple i've
been in a situation where previously i
was in multiple meetings at the same
time yeah
how i know why ridiculous i've seen
questions and lead like lead
presentations in both of them oh my god
i'm not sure that's something to be
proud of like you sometimes you just get
so busy that you just gotta do it
anyways we're gonna kick off first with
our usual what we've been playing
segment and what we've been experiencing
consuming because we are for our sins
consumers
um and then we'll probably go into a
topic of the week
which i literally came up with moments
ago it's a good one though
because we looked at the sheet and we're
like we should go two hours there's
nothing we don't have enough to talk
about for two hours so tomorrow does
what he does best and pulled something
out
um yeah so uh we'll we'll get to that
eventually um and it'll be a good
opportunity for the chat to get involved
because it is kind of like a
hypothetical situation and also i don't
want to say what it is now because it's
going to derail everything um but let's
start with what we've been playing and
we're going to kick off with
jean-luc
what you've been up to uh
well the big one i played was i got to
play a little bit of plaguetail requiem
you lucky son of a [ __ ] a little bit
early uh i think it's the
same is it the same demo that's the
tribeca
so if you had access to
i don't know what was it you paid five
dollars and you could play it five
dollars and you could play three games
from that list you could have played
like cuphead and um
the other stuff well cuphead's like out
in like yeah a week right like really
soon yeah so like um but yeah i gotta
play a little bit of uh plaguetail
requiem it is
uh very much more plague tale
it's kind of a weird game to demo
because i feel like plague tells so much
about the
um
uh like just like that narrative and
getting invested in the characters and
like what's happening so they're just
like they throw you into like chapter
three and you're like i have
okay still loads of rats
tons of rats the rat tech is still on
point have they have they trademarked
rat tech yet because i would i want to
see the game opened with a logo for rat
heck
yeah oh like a like a speed tree
situation
yeah
yeah rat tech is good uh those rats are
just
everywhere um
it doesn't feel as big of a like
generational leap as the first one i
would say um like it's definitely gonna
look better and play better but as
someone who like just recently played uh
innocence like last year on the series x
i was like this looks fairly comparable
to what the the first one did i'm sure
like some of the
uh like character models and fidelity
looks better um
did it get
uh series x upgrades
yes and that's how i played it it's a
very good version of that game yeah too
so it's a great game i really enjoyed it
and it picks up where the last game left
off right
yes um
so i guess slight spoilers for the end
of plaguetail requiem um but like
innocence innocence i must say don't you
dare spoil this game for me john luke
but uh
at the end of that game they're like oh
we're
they basically just like leave
whatever place they're in and they're
like we gotta go find safety and then
you are in this
town
i'm not sure why are they still in
france i think so there's a town
rattenburg or something like that i want
this game no i was gonna be like is it a
town overrun by cats like for safety
oh that's fine that'd be smart
we can only defeat these rats with an
equally large number of like evil cats
that would be amazing
no so you
yeah they're like in this town and uh
hugo the little kid is like ill so you
have to go find some nice shade for him
and then and so amicia and lucas are
like heading off to go
find him um find him that like
nightshade
uh
just bad shit's happening constantly um
the
part of the town is uh
infected with rats but the guards aren't
telling anyone and they're just
murdering everyone in that like area to
keep it contained
um
eventually you like so you kind of like
go through this sort of quarantined area
and then you come out into like the
countryside because you're trying to
find this um
like herbalist who's got the medicine
and i would say
the interesting thing
that they did was
they
for the most part the gameplay feels
very much the same you know it's like
okay like yep i got my slingshot i got
my pots i can um throw
uh like extinguish or whatever it's
called igneous no igneous is the one
this is the one that turns up lights on
you can light on fire and then it's like
extinguish i don't know they sound like
harry potter
spells
pocket sound
basically
so you can like you know uh
disable the lights or the the torches
and then like the rats just eat everyone
um
the whole thing in this one is like
this is like uh amisi's like last of us
part two where it's like oh she's like
jaded she's like grizzled she's angry
yeah
hench
every time you kill someone should be
like yeah you dogs that's what you
deserved and then like lucas is like
chill out like what
what is going on so
does the combat and gameplay kind of
reflect her more aggressive experience
side because i remember a big part of
plague tale innocence as it was called
was like her loss of innocence and how
she kind of becomes a cold-blooded
killer because like
yeah i'm curious how the game plays
itself yeah at least in this slice it
was mostly very much the same like you
you still have to be very stealthy like
you're gonna get um like killed right
away but they added some interesting
mechanics like there's now a counter
system where you can actually kind of
like push a guy away from you so it's
like she's kind of got a little more
like she's a little more feisty now yes
you don't have a knife you're not like
sneaking up on people and like stabbing
their throats and [ __ ] no no you can't
there is a knife you do get a knife and
you can go up and straight up stab
people but it's like a one time
it is a one-time use knife though so you
it's like the shiv's in last yeah it's a
little more strategic well that's kind
of nice i know because you only use it
once yeah
i see you've played knife booney before
is there is there a greater focus on
combat i couldn't really in the gameplay
thing that showed up today like there
was it was mostly combat i'm like oh i
kind of missed the
more puzzle
like stealth yeah so there's still
plenty of that and in fact like kind of
one of the culminating areas in the demo
was this section where you um
kind of you have to like get through
this huge group of enemies and you
definitely have to stealth it but it
felt like it felt a little more open
than the previous games where it
actually was like oh there's clearly
multiple different paths i could take
and it's like oh i could hide behind
here if like a guy shows up or i could
go this way so it seems like they're
trying to expand just sort of like the
um
like the areas themselves and it's not
just like this linear straight shot
um like through each area where it's
like there's very clearly like the right
way to do it like it felt a little more
open which i thought was cool um and
then at the end of the demo there is
this whole section where like amisi is
like um screw this i'm like i'm over
this and you just straight up have this
like showdown where you kill like 20
guards
and i like what they're doing with it i
will say some of the voice acting from
her got like a little goofy um
she's putting on her like
batman voice when she was trying to
sound like intense so she's like
i'm just tired of this lucas i need to
kill them all like she would like put on
this gravelly voice and i'm like origin
story french is first i'm just like
this just kind of reads a little more
hokey than like
i wanted part of it's the accent too
because i know they all have french
accents so i wonder if like that kind of
factors into it a little
like i just kind of found it a little
more silly than like serious i was like
okay all right
but she's got a crossbow in this one
yeah i didn't get to use the crossbow or
anything so i think that's the
interesting stuff because i feel like
that is where they would get more into
like combat combat right and like really
wanting to because it was still very
much like slingshot you can only hit the
guys if they don't have the helmet so
yeah that thing so yeah i think overall
i'm just super curious how the combat
progression is gonna be because i felt
like that was so meaningful in the first
game in terms of how you kind of become
the master of the environment you're
able to use the rats to help fight
things with you and i know lucas is sick
so he's not or not lucas the kid
hugo hugo is sick so he's not with you
to do that kind of stuff but i'm curious
like how you
how you progress the game play with a
character who's like already
ready to kill and like i guess it's
getting a crossbow which
yeah the natural progression yeah which
doesn't feel as natural
did you watch the gameplay livestream
thing that they did that happened no i
didn't get around to it i would say
there's just this moment where like she
uh misia is just so hurt that she just
turns to hugo and she's like no it's
okay go for it do it we have to and he
takes control of the rats and you use
the rats to just kill everyone there so
like
part
controlling the rats
dc
yeah like yeah like the dc here like
it's controlling the rats and directing
them to like kill everyone there so i
think there will be a part of the game
where like hugo is i think i complete
the original does he like become rat man
in
he has the white rats and you have the
black rats and there's some weird like
racial
just going for like a last of us kind of
like tone like is it going to end with a
messier like trying to drown a rat and
crying at the same time or something but
it feels like i hope so i don't know
yeah like the pied piper comes in
no i want i want the abbey uh early
fight but with amicia and a rat like
half a frame by frame
like a dark souls bloodborne giant
that's kind of cinematic where they're
like fighting and amusing is trying to
drown the rat and gets upper hand and
tries to drown her and it's just like so
halfway through you get to play the rat
yeah yeah
oh yeah
yeah that would be pretty sick i'd play
that game
um someone in chat asked is there a time
jump from end of first game to i'm not
actually sure because because again the
demo started me oh yeah and part way
through the games
no he doesn't look that much i was gonna
say it's gotta only be like a few months
okay if if that like there's yeah not
like a serious time skip didn't i think
they used actual like to play him was an
actual like toddler i think who who
yeah so i'm curious how
because it's been years since that one
came out right 2019 i'm sure they
recorded it well before that too i
wonder how they're going about with the
voice recording if it's not supposed to
take place
that much far after i think i could be
wrong but i'm pretty sure they actually
had kids because i saw a video where
they were like we really wanted this to
feel authentic so we wanted to have kids
read
like all of these characters mostly kids
right mm-hmm yeah they cost a lot of
rats as well for this yeah yeah yeah
each and every year each individual just
baby run they've got little mic set up
that's what i want to see they're in
these little little tiny like it's just
like eat i can't do that again but with
less
please
um if you're watching on twitch you will
know that now we've just been raided by
a giant bomb if you're not watching on
twitch and you're listening to this
later as i said at the top of what
you're doing with your life
we value all of anyone here
appreciate all that um welcome raiders
yes this room is dark but it's
atmospheric and it's it's called game
spot after dark yeah exactly
um the rooms are work in progress did
you see any rat kings
no
not a single right any last of us rap
kings no
well we taught dan riker about rat kings
the other day and he's horrible he's
horrified by water right do you know
what racking is i don't know i mean
there's nothing you don't know a
wrecking ball there's a gun in destiny
do not bring up pictures in a situation
where rats can get tangled together
their tails get tangled together yeah
and they become a giant ball of rats
yeah i mean that basically kind of
happened that's why the last of us part
two
enemy that you fight is called
king yeah
i do remember hearing that that enemy
was called rat king and i was like
that's a weird name i guess but i didn't
look into it and i i guess i'm kind of
glad i just i'm betting good money there
will be a giant ball of rats in the new
plaguetail game i mean they're kind of
oh it must be there has to be that's the
only like there's it's already like they
move like water it's just like about to
say that the livestream today ended with
them about to be engulfed by like a
tidal wave of rats so like well that's
tidal wave of frat not right yeah
different thing i see when you said rat
king i just pictured a rat with a little
crown
um but yeah that sounds like
are you excited about this having
finished oh yeah i'm very excited about
it i mean like i said
as a demo it's a little more like yep
this plays like the first game a couple
changes um for me it's more just like i
really got invested in those characters
in that world
so i'm like i just kind of want to see
where the story goes
um but the gameplay was never like
i don't know like the gameplay was good
but it was never the strongest part of
the game like it felt like it could use
more improvement and i will say that
like what i saw in the demo felt more of
the same so i'm like a little like i was
kind of hoping it to be a little bit
more um but also it's still like a very
early slice like i don't have the
crossbow yet maybe the crossbow changes
everything yeah yeah as crossbows doing
games i've learned anything introducing
a bow or a crossbow into a game that's
that's that's that's me that's the
mechanic
brotherhood they added a crossbow best
assassin far cry far cry 3. let's throw
a cross or let's throw a bow and arrow
in here change the game yup yup true
um
yeah exciting times uh i think the the
the actual
uh the the game the first game was such
a surprise for a lot of people oh yeah
that i kind of i'm interested to see
where they go with it because then when
you have that situation you're like we
can even stick close to what we
unexpectedly delivered on or we can try
and do something different
um i hope that they
it doesn't stick too close and it seems
like some of the stuff that they showed
off already was like we're going to keep
it familiar but there is opportunity to
kind of expand a bit more on it and my
hope is that they do that because just
another one of these games will probably
be fine but it feels like they built so
much goodwill with that original game
that they this is a good moment for them
to leverage that and be like hey we're
more than just a one-trick pony like one
hit one yeah
yeah so fingers crossed is there a
release date for it yet they announced
it today october october 15th
18th
do they have a cool like um pining pun
for it as well like rat day is
hashtag right
and they don't have emergency holes do
they in those that in that game they
kind of do no they do they do they have
them
honestly that would fit extremely well
they could totally do that and i feel
like that's fine yeah well she's got a
sling right she could like you know how
they yeah twirl the grenades and gears
of war yeah yeah and then she could yell
like eat [ __ ] grub or whatever marcus
okay you know yeah if she if she like
leans into the voice and just does her
best marcus phoenix impression
yeah we said batman it was actually it
was actually
that's actually what they're doing has
anyone made the plaguetail meme where
it's the tony soprano from the sopranos
where he's like got that guy and he's
like good morning rat
someone used to photoshop that and just
having
a rat
that would be so good get to work chat
expect it delivered by the end of the
season
um the only thing i've been checking out
um which i think jake's also been
playing is neon white yo which is
see normally that'd be something that we
cut out but since it's live
as how it goes
who doesn't have a steam deck here is it
lucy are you and i the only ones who
don't have one here i bought a new pc
yeah yeah but it's not a steam deck no
but it's a new pc it's very expensive
i was like
i i keep
trying
to sign up i like i get to the point
where i open the page on steam
and i can put my email and whatever in
and i just like i don't do i was sat
next to tam when i did it and i was like
do i want one of these and he went yes
and so i closed the tab
because
i want to lead me astray i'll enable
anything oh yeah neon white so i've been
playing it on switch because i don't
have a steam deck and i've been
traveling this week so i was like i'm
going to try it on switch how is it on
switch
it it's pretty solid in terms of frame
rate i think it does 60 it someone told
me it rarely ever drops on twitter 720p
i think it's 720p i've only played
handheld i haven't actually tried on a
tv so like it looks good on an oled
screen from what i've played so far
it still feels pretty good now obviously
it's not as precise as if you were
playing on a pc
uh but that said like honestly that
hasn't really been much of an issue for
me and it's maybe it's because i haven't
experienced it on pc but i've still been
able to hit what i'm aiming at there
were like a couple situations where i
was having trouble hitting certain
things but like it's still addicting as
hell like i
want to not use addicting describe games
so i apologize but
i i i it it's all i've been thinking
about like i started playing it last
week and i just want to play more
do you still have the leaderboards on
switch you still have the leaderboards i
think i'm the only one of my friends
which is playing so i can't respect
anyone which is one of the coolest parts
when
yeah exactly
um that's why i picked it up on pc like
the deciding factor was like well
everyone i know is playing it on pc and
like i loaded it up and i saw ben jank
at the top of the leaderboards and i
said i'm going to crush all not on my
watch
did it work did you do it i did oh wow i
mean i i haven't he maybe he's gone back
and beat me but like i it brought out a
competitive boy's got too much 14 to
play
then go play more 14. let me just
absolutely destroy let me be the king
i think like i playing it on pc and
mouse and keyboard is like the way to go
oh yeah i'm sure it is but i think if
switch is your only option it is totally
do not pass up on this game just because
switch is your only option we described
what it is
no i just went right into it uh it is it
was like a speed running
sort of first person shooter it's a
speed running card game card game
[Music]
card game feels weird because like the
cards aren't really like it's a first
person platformer yes which where level
b
where speed is of the essence
but your
moment-to-moment interactions are on top
of guiding the character are using or
burning cards to give you additional
um kind of
movement options so you can do things
like and and
you also have to kind of like factor
those cards into eliminating enemies
which as far as you can tell you cannot
complete a level without taking out all
the enemies correct
so you might have a
for example a cluster of enemies and a
card that allows you if you play it
normally you throw out a bomb that
explodes and if you're close enough you
can use that to do like a bomb jump a
rocket jump
you can also
for example burn that card to give you a
double jump for example so it's a case
of like
very quickly using and burning cards and
making moment-to-moment decision as
you're moving lightning fast and trying
to get from the start to the end of the
level and in terms of like how the
actual levels are constructed they're
like best described
as kind of like the surf maps from
counter-strike back in the day so there
was a subset of mods in counter-strike
where the whole point was using the
physics of the game to basically
go from start to finish and glide
basically um it's kind of like what's
the um ubisoft racing game uh
track mania a bit track mania-ish um and
then on top of that as lucy said there's
a um
visual novel layer to it and there's a
story being told and it's very heavy at
the start say how good is the story
everyone i know only talks about like
the levels themselves not the actual
story yeah i mean like it's an
interesting conceit that you're an
assassin and you're taken from hell to
heaven and you basically get to earn
your redemption by killing as many
demons as possible yeah yeah
and your character has amnesia but then
everyone else is like oh hey it's you
and he's like i don't know who you are
yeah i think the the problem with the
narrative is not the narrative itself
it's that the core gameplay is so
much fun and so engaging that the
narrative
the visual novel element of it just
serves to keep you away from that so
it's taking away from the stuff you want
up front the first hour is a lot of like
set up and that kind of stuff and you're
like i just want to do the running like
i just wanted one i find myself skipping
through a lot of it some of the writing
is a bit
yeah there's a john cena joke which i
was like
oh yeah it's very try hard cool modern
edgy and i'm like you're not hitting any
of those notes well like this
i don't mean to [ __ ] on it but like the
writing's not great yeah i feel like a
top ten contender for the year but maybe
but it's not like like definitely
one i like to story more than most i
agree it's not like amazing but like i
enjoy the characters enough and i think
it feeds really good into the uh running
stuff where there's also presents you
can find in each level um that actually
encourages you to like uh kind of like
go off to the path and look for them
yeah and they're fun they're like
puzzles yeah they're like little puzzles
you have to do because it's like oh you
have to
the the path you'd have to take to get
like say the best time requires you to
like burn this card here and do this and
do this but instead you actually want to
save the card so that you can get up to
this like really high platform off to
the side so like requires you to like
use alternative thinking
like you can do a present run and then a
speed exactly yeah completion run like
that yeah but it also unlocks like
side missions and i don't know if you
guys have done many of these for certain
characters and they're really cool
because they're very focused on one
ability or one sort of rule set
and like there's one
i forget who has it but basically i have
to use the bombs to like platform across
the entire area there's no like flat
places for you to stand it's all like
sticking bombs to a wall and using that
to keep jumping higher yeah it it and
there's like platformers that are just
covered in spikes and you have to like
zip
around pretty carefully so like those
missions are cool so i think it's worth
collecting the presents and having those
conversations so you can at least see
those even if you're not into the story
but i will say a lot of the characters
to me feel like they were trying to go
for the whole like hades sort of like
yeah look at this present stuff as well
yeah look at these very attractive like
i hope the internet latches on to these
characters and i'm not really getting
that vibe i mean i love the designs i
want the design
i love i think neon white's a voice
actor is also steve bloom oh yeah
oh i was like i mean yeah oh good
it fits them yeah it feels really well
yeah um
i
what a grab for an indicator i know
right
it's ai
the characters are
they're a certain ilk it feels like
they're very much pulled from anime
stereotypes and character archetypes as
well there's the eagle and there's the
mysterious tsundere like sniper girl
there's the yeah makoto everyone's all
the everyone's here all the archetypes
are here
and i think like so far it doesn't
really do anything to subvert that so
yeah like maybe it does later on but
um i think my favorite part about the
story is how
just
absolute dicks the angels are yeah like
you're in like heaven
and they are just like oh look at this
excellent uh heaven ice cream we're
having it's so tasty like we can have
that as much as we want and they're like
and they're like oh [ __ ] like
hell likes trash scum like they're just
like [ __ ] don't care about you at all
and i'm like wow okay
yeah i guess trash scum you are in hell
yeah well where and how
they're just like they're just like
heaven is a great place and they're like
but god doesn't care about you and i'm
like jesus okay yeah
so i like that aspect i think it's one
of those games that
it's there's certain games that you play
which are like they take something
that a subset of people who play games
are capable of doing and make it
uh attainable and accessible for
everyone
like i don't know um
i was trying to figure out but like uh i
can't think of a good example but like
you know
to a better to a to not a specific not a
particularly great example but like
eldon ring makes the souls formula more
approachable for a lot of people by
giving them options for example like
more people are likely to understand
from software's games and feel good
about playing them and really get the
magic of them by playing elden ring then
perhaps something like dark souls 1
which is like more punishing
um but you get the vibe and you get the
kind of like what makes it special i
think this is this does the same for
speed running where it's like it's very
approachable it's very playable for
pretty much everyone and
just by playing it you get the vibe of
oh this is what it feels like to be a
speed runner yes and there's a lot of
magic in that you might not stick with
it but
it kind of reminds me and and it's easy
to feel good at the game it reminds me
of when you do a a good run in mirror's
edge like when you first started playing
mirror's edge and you were like
oh this feels really good like and it's
different and i don't feel like i'm
screwing and then obviously they
introduce the people the guns and you're
like
i'm terrible at this why is everyone
shooting me what's going on
um oh now i'm sad because but like
they're not going to even know where is
that yeah
but it's one of those games that i would
say like i'd recommend to pretty much
anyone just to give it a try yeah um and
chances are you'll appreciate its design
if not really get enveloped by its story
and characters the world is cool looking
mm-hmm it reminds me reminding me a
little bit of um paradise killer yeah
yeah
yeah there's a period where i was
confusing those two and the music is
great it's got like loki drum and bass
like style um music um i would
absolutely buy the final
yeah is it if they release a vinyl that
would be like one of those things sounds
like yeah it's cool yeah and um maria
points out perfect timing with gdq
around the corner i can't wait to see
what people do
yeah
oh people are going to do some wild [ __ ]
yeah even like trying to beat people's
times i feel like you figure out
interesting routes that you don't feel
like you were supposed to do like
sometimes you use a bomb to just skip
half the level and you're like oh okay
well this just shaved off like four
seconds right yeah and i feel like there
is going to be a lot of malleability in
terms of like how people actually
complete these levels and how they can
and then once you add in the ways people
break the game i'm sure it'll be even
wilder oh yeah yeah um playing on steam
deck is pretty good if you use the weird
touchpad thing oh really yeah so i i
originally was playing on mouse and
keyboard and i was like i don't want to
play on steam deck because of the stick
forgetting that it's got the uh weird
little touchpad thing and it's not as
quick because you can't flick your wrist
to like do quick turns in that stuff but
like you can like glide your thumb over
quickly to make quick adjustments so it
is a nice middle ground between a
controller and a mouse i think yeah um
so if you do have a steam deck just look
at that steam website don't worry about
it just yeah just
just pre-orders
i mean like if you pre-ordered it now
you probably wouldn't get it for a while
and by the time it becomes available to
you you'll be up for it and you also
don't pay for it all up front you just
put five dollars down to and then you
make the decision yeah and then you make
the decision so that's what i'm saying
which is the good one the one with the
more i'm not getting the 650 don't can
you put an um
which is why a lot of people i think
bought the cheapest one yeah i think the
there's like the most expensive one has
a better screen it does yeah yeah and
the ssd is a bit bigger
yeah it's like 500.
um but
it's a later loose it's a later lucy
problem like you don't have to you'll be
fine oh i have steam credit
you have enough i must say no i have
about 19
also buying this as i've realized will
get you a [ __ ] ton of like steam you
know what's a good good value for you
know what makes it a better value you
already own a bunch of games for it i do
own a lot yeah there's probably a lot of
games that you haven't played yet as
well imagine that you could point
on it it opens like holiday silks i have
hollow knight on my eyes it opens the
door for you to enjoy your library to
the fullest now no longer are you tied
to your mouse and keyboard and chair and
there's a lot of like it's i don't know
it's fun to like just
mess around and like try again be like
ooh how will this play off like portable
like you know okay [ __ ] now we're
talking i did i okay
on the go i reserved the middle one
i'll watch two on the go yeah that'll be
good um yeah so
neon white well worth playing
um
what else is going on who else and jake
you only have neon white listed here is
there anything further you want to say
about it no i i think we covered it
pretty thoroughly i haven't like i said
i've been out of town so i haven't
really been playing busy moving much
yeah just playing stuff on my switch
good
uh
jordan
i say i haven't really been playing
anything
new since getting back from l.a uh
i
i'm always playing apex i will never
stop playing apex i'll probably stop
playing apex when they finally release
titanfall 3
uh whenever that happens
look if silk songs dream can be kept
alive then titanfall 3's dream can be
kept alive as much as you do but
it'll happen one day eventually at some
point people will get tired of apex
legends i don't know when that day isn't
it
yeah you're playing yourself here well
yeah you're part of the problem now it's
still fun
i'm not gonna stop playing it for a
while also it's making ea like what a
billion dollars or something like that
so yeah uh i i don't think i don't think
respawn i don't think respawn can
willingly stop supporting they just need
to go in there and be like what if we
made a single player apex legends game
and they'd be like oh
i like the way this goes yeah
and then before they know it title four
three exists
it's called but it's just called titans
it's called it's called apex
it's called apex but the e is a three
yeah
this is good
i would say a lot of people are
wondering because uh a lot of respawn
folks who were doing stuff on titanfall
2 and jedi fallen order they have
recently left respawn and they're making
their own studio called gravity well oh
yeah and they haven't announced like
what game they're making a lot of people
were like what if they just make what's
essentially titanfall 3 like without
getting sued for essentially exactly
what you won though
no
even if it was a game that like
mechanically felt like titanfall you'd
still be missing the titanfall part of
it it's like if they re if they took
every member of the marvel universe and
created a different universe i'd be like
isn't that what the mcu technically is i
want no but if it was like instead of
spider-man it was like
i know
you want the license that's true that's
true
you're not getting bt in there again if
you don't know
yeah
there could be a new bt
bt junior
doesn't tb sound for something
but yeah just uh apex is also just going
through an issue right now where it's
broken to hell on xbox uh
yeah the
for whatever reason it doesn't read
input delays it doesn't read inputs
correctly so it's delayed on
everything so when you're trying to like
switch guns it takes like
a half second longer when you're trying
to like sprint it takes like a second
and a half for the game to register that
you're trying to sprint which
in a first person shooter is like
everything that's a wild problem yeah
this many years into that game
do you only play on xbox or do you
pretty much only play on xbox because i
mostly played on playstation and i was
like i'm gonna try pc in good lord the
skill level oh yeah takes a huge like
i've done like i've done warzone from
like xbox pc and i've done some other
shooters and it's been largely okay but
man apex legends is brutal on pc at
least for an idiot like me
the level of play that yeah if you're a
pc player
a friend of mine
uh last week said the word or said the
sentence i think i might read art of war
to prepare better for apex legends
online
just a friend of mine
and he's like i think it'll just help me
with my tactics and i'm like
they were not talking about i don't know
what the [ __ ] assault rifles that
people were toting back then
yeah what separates us from like
travelling
you need to interview your friend like a
month from now and ask him like his game
i would commission that friend to write
what war taught me about
that i would actually click the hell out
of that yeah i would read that and then
it's like the whole thing was nothing
nothing i would still be like that was
worth the read
how long is the art of war
it's very short yeah okay wait remember
i had a pocket sized one that i kept oh
yeah he said try lance's which i got
because i thought it helped me with
chemistry
so it is real there's a cycle to it i
knew it
was street fighter and counter-strike
mainly tryline says there is an audio
book of the art of war could you imagine
like trust me just listen to it
you don't need it it didn't help me with
street fighter at all or counter-strike
so
uh but you're ready for real war now
yeah you really wanted to do it you read
the art of war and you play like total
ball yeah yeah that would probably well
i haven't read it i don't know so maybe
it wouldn't come in handy but in my head
that makes more sense yeah it's not
going to work yeah i don't i don't think
sun tzu is going to be writing anything
about like ttk or anything is it
like in india or bt or tv
no that's not happening um yeah so
you're playing
apex wells uh say uh since uh my
volleyball league is uh taking a
short break the past few weeks um i've
been jumping back into switch sports uh
volleyball so i'm now the highest rank
in that so i should theoretically
play any of the other sports at this
point
but i'm like
but i'm also at the top and i can just
if i keep playing i'll remain at the top
and
yeah i'm just i'm just i'm just going to
keep playing
volleyball virtually until real
volleyball comes back my poor partner uh
they're very patient with me and just
being like are you still playing
volleyball like 3
a.m to play and they're like i don't
want to play volleyball i want to
we're at the top of the leaderboard and
we're staying here no i'm the
cruel unsupportive partner it's like oh
you're you're just not good enough at
volleyball so i'm gonna play myself
suffering from success
[Laughter]
uh lucy what have you been up to uh i've
been playing the quarry i've been
playing a lot neon white but i've been
playing the quarry on stream and that is
a very fun time um how is it is it until
dawn like level or more like well the
creepy stuff hasn't happened yet oh so
how far are you into this stuff doesn't
really happen
i'm at the end of i'm sorry in chapter
three tonight that's a long time to go
without any creepy stuff happening i'm
at chapter
nine
no reviews done and like what the [ __ ]
is like
there's nothing scary in it there's
maybe i'm like immune to it but it does
have like moments i'm like i had a
couple of moments where just like
someone would walk in the background of
a frame and i'll go
but nothing
it feels designed to make streamers
overreact more than actually scare
people if you know
it's good marketing well the problem is
so i'm playing on pc and um really
putting that investment to work
playing it on like everything max and
whatever my pc is good enough to handle
it but like the
the sink with the the the mouth stuff
like some of the characters that have a
really good mouth tech
like brenda song's character model is
they spent a lot of money on brenda's
song and they didn't spend they took all
the money from the water tech and they
put it in brenda song face yeah because
this one will be perfect
the water looks absolutely atrocious
like it's hilarious it's like sludge
like moving around and maybe that's the
monster tan what's going on yeah it's so
hilarious but then it cuts to brenda
song and you're like that's a real
person
yeah sometimes she genuinely just looks
like a real person like she her model is
so good but some of them don't
look bang on and like the mouse is kind
of broken and sometimes the game just
like the audio goes out of sync and i'm
like
and then chat i'll go no no it's it's
just this happens to everyone they also
do that thing where sometimes the
character will smile and show way too
much gum
like
you know let's go really
and like there's some wild faces in that
[ __ ] because every time you make a
decision the game just zooms in on a
character's face and then slows it down
but just in the most awkward frames ever
and then you're just kind of there for a
while and so sometimes there'll be
something really serious happening and
then someone just looking like they've
entered a gurning competition or
something or their neck is a weird angle
i really enjoy it have you figured out
what the villain more or less it like
what the
supernatural enemy is
okay because you have no check i won't
spoil it but i think like for me
personally i don't find that concept
that scary so for me that took a lot of
the mystery and wind out of the
scarier aspects of the game
uh but i don't think that's necessarily
a bad thing someone pointed out in the
chat that like a schlocky horror like to
be honest i'm there to see people die in
really gruesome ways because i think
until dawn is still them strongest i
agree well i think the benefit of until
dawn was since it was the first one you
were like oh is this an actual
supernatural thing or is this just
someone [ __ ] with them
i think another thing for me is from a
writing perspective i feel like they hit
the balance way better with until dawn
where it was like
they i prefer the characters in this one
though
for now
at one point i was like i want to kill
every single one and i do it not even a
song even brenda's song there's moments
where i was like you are awful there was
a there was a moment in i'm not going to
spoil what it was but there was such a
[ __ ] girl on girl moment in chapter
yeah exactly that i was genuinely like
furious like i would not be friends with
her
i would never talk to her just killed
him lucy
the thing is i had i had that moment
immediately after that where i was like
she's got to go and then like
to their credit a series of things
happened where i was like
okay this character has now earned a
reprieve from death so i would love it
for now
yeah but do you have everything for like
controlling this you know there's a
puppet master watching us and we're all
just one moment away from so so like
i hope it's not a gamer who's in control
of it
i think what i was going to say is like
until dawn hit the balance of being like
schlocky teen
you know uh survival horror and writing
um
almost like they knew what they were
going for and anytime there was an
awkwardly awkwardly delivered line or
awkward bit of dialogue it felt
on purpose it felt like it was on
purpose they did it on purpose this
feels like
it's
they're going for that but they've also
accidentally got a bunch of bad writing
in there
and
it constantly swings between because
there's times where it's way way more
like immediate plot holes like something
or someone will say or behave in a way
that i'm like
that's baffling i don't understand 186
endings yeah i'm curious how it's going
to end for you guys because like i said
last week my ending was
it just felt incomplete there were plot
holes there were things that were like
you could tell there were scenes missing
because it would fade it would be
focused on certain characters fade to
black and then fade back into the same
characters and it's like okay clearly
there's something that's supposed to go
there yeah there's one character i think
justice smith is
the weakest part of that cast
like he's right he plays ryan oh yeah is
he's the podcast listener he just he's
not hey he might listen to after dark
all right
because they like really at the
beginning they really pitch him as
almost like the protagonist kind of yeah
he's he's like
unbelievable he gets worse and worse
with really seen yeah it's reached a
point now where i'm like
you deserve to die like everything bad
should happen to you he's like also like
his delivery is like
he is just not at all trying like he's
he's he delivers he delivers his lines
like he's got his breakfast in his mouth
still and he's just like
it's not like he can't act like he can
actually it might have been bad
direction pikachu i don't know if it was
bad direction he just seems everyone
else is going for it like they're really
doing it like there's the kid who plays
dylan who's like
he's like
he swings back and forth between being
annoying and and like is actually kind
of fun but how much of that do you think
is due to the choices you're making and
not so much
i mean still i guess that is
inconsistent if you're able to make
choices that vary that widely but do you
think there's a way where you could play
it where his character would have made
more sense uh ryan no no sorry sorry
dylan i mean either character i guess i
think the thing that i find annoying
about dylan is his personality more than
anything yeah um not like my sweet dylan
he's good he's fond but he's got like
that kind of weird he has these weird
moments where he's like
he seeks approval from people in a way
that's very strange that it's like very
out of character for him so like he
swings his personality swings in very
weird there's like the opening scene
at the beginning where he's in the
office with ryan yeah and it's like
that's when he was good like he's being
smooth like you know what you should get
well yeah yeah he's like trying to get
flirty with him but then at the same
time he also keeps being like creepy
creepy or like what if i take this gun
and like really and then ryan's like
don't do that and he's like
fine see that that's the better that
went back to being flurry initially
that's a bit where i was like this is a
weird and then later on they returned to
that exact moment and ryan's like
it's kind of a minor spoiler there's
like a a kind of like a
a back and forth about who should have
the gun
and ryan is like so annoying in that
scene because he's like i'm the only
should have a gun it's like why you suck
you should not yeah and meanwhile like
the person who has proved himself to be
the best with the gun
at no point goes i think i should have
the gun
even it's like the brenda song scene
that's what i'm talking about she rolls
up and she's like boom boom boom expert
ultimate and then she's like no i don't
want to go
you just there is a way to get her a gun
but yeah but that's that situation felt
weird because it's like
like
who who in their might right mind would
not want to give her the gun yeah
because
but yeah justin smith is like
he's he stands out because as you get
further and further along he keeps
making decisions and justifying and
aligning himself with like purposes that
feel
so so dumb and like i'm convinced like
if it doesn't end with him being some
sort of
like
oh it's more to his character than what
there is currently i'll be very shocked
because his characterization is just
wildly a quiet guy who likes podcasts
he's not until he stops
like what's wrong with you
um and like there's other characters who
are like and it stands out because
there's i think his name jacob the other
guy yeah that's his name
he's the classic like douche like uh
frat boy but he's he's consistent at
least yeah consistently he's my favorite
he has
again i'm very early on but like the bit
with him and emma in the um
the um like the stock yeah
any any walks past the thing in melons
and i was streaming it and i was like if
he doesn't pick up two of those
and then he immediately does it i was
like
yes and he maintains that kind of vibe
and like his changes in his character
feel earned or they feel natural where
it's like he's simply and hard for emma
so like everything that happens to him
is through the lens of simping for emma
yeah whereas like ryan just one minute
he's like this and the next minute
you're like he's just saying the most
like mind-boggling things where you're
like what's wrong with you what happened
so you just want to be more consistent
not to be a better and also like the
problem with ryan is he feels like a
plant where things are happening and
it's like he doesn't see it like he's
like ambivalent to things that happen
like for example this is not what
happens but like
there might be one character who murders
another character and he'll be like well
maybe that character's got some good
ideas like
what are you talking about you just
watch this happen like what
we don't know the whole story it's that
level of like just completely oblivious
to everything happening around him and
you're like you feel like it starts to
feel like he's there to facilitate like
pushing through plot holes
and it just becomes a point where i'm
like i don't like you at all but like
it's kind of interesting because
i'm clearly invested in the cast at the
same time like the
the fact that i don't like ryan as much
as i don't like him clearly means that
i'm
like engaged with the rest of the cast
and
and in that and through that kind of
like understanding
supermassive is doing a good job of
creating these characters they might be
there being like yes i plan to make ryan
an annoying [ __ ] back has worked they're
listening to this podcast yes
he thinks he's criticizing us but
actually he's falling into our trap
i think to your point though with until
dawn i was i right when i started that
game i felt like i wasn't supposed to
like any of these characters and i feel
like i felt like that was very
intentional with this it definitely
feels up in the air like some characters
i really don't like and i'm not sure if
i'm supposed to or not supposed to while
other characters i like and i'm like but
i don't know if i should like this scary
it it it feels
i guess it feels pretty mixed into my
cast because like until dawn has that
scene at the beginning where like they i
forget exactly what they do but they
like oh i remember what they do
oh girl with the crush yes
yeah
it's [ __ ] up yeah they do the same
thing and so you're like all these
people are going to die horribly and i'm
excited
i think the most exciting thing that you
can look forward to as player is like
that's not the entire cast oh yeah
there's more characters i've seen i've
seen a couple like there's one there's
one character a woman who shows up and i
was like immediately my favorite yeah
you know who i'm talking about she rolls
up and she's like
ready to do business and i'm like she's
the best easily the best and then you
get to play an extended segment about
her and her story and you're like this
is cool yeah yeah it's a [ __ ] metal
gear character out of nowhere
but yeah i'm enjoying the game i think
it's like writing is a bit inconsistent
but
fundamentally i think it's the best
games they've made since until dawn um
and uh they clearly have a place within
the kind of industry like no one's
making games like they are
no one's making that specific kind of
game and i hope they continue to and i
hope it's a success
um
and uh i just i'm interested
they're in a tricky spot because any
time they do a a game that isn't like
teenage slasher fake people just are
like
but they could involve the formula in
some way it's not like life is strange
remain the same game through all of its
iterations so like they they could
probably find a way to evolve the
mechanics of
the style of game yeah be the killer
yeah i do think it would be fun to like
have a bunch of game spot people stream
it past the controller do the whole
multiplayer everyone takes different
characters you know what i would love to
see them do like get an actual license
properly like give them yeah give them
scream or friday
would be amazing would be really good
yeah that would be such a good thing it
makes perfect sense because that's the
stream renaissance give someone a
control of uh ghost face exactly yeah
yeah that'd be pretty because like they
like they're clearly open to it like
those movie um uh publishers are giving
like ilfonic a bunch of their properties
to make like yeah yeah games
just rolling yeah they're making and
they're making games that are like not
naturally fitting in within that kind of
universes it makes sense for like
someone to go like hey we've got this
thing that you're clearly inspired by do
you want to just make something in there
like i would love to see like someone be
bald enough to be like our next entry in
this historic so uh horror franchise
isn't a movie it's a game and it's an
interactive game so the next i don't
know
uh
freddy krueger movie or even like a you
know scream or friday 13th or whatever
it may be is a game made by supermassive
i'd love to see them yeah like get the
writers to like come in like for
screaming yeah i mean like i feel like
even even
if they made a game as good as the
quarry in the scream universe for
example that would be pretty special
like that would be pretty cool because
you have girl's face and that kind of
stuff and and also like the idea like
that whole thing with the ramy mother
character in until dawn start with where
he was [ __ ] with people like that's
just at the front i can't get over the
fact that it was wrong yeah that's just
a beat from screen like remember right
and they like they they had that thing
where i was like who is the who's ghost
face and oh thailand says evil dead
yeah yeah yeah
i feel like i feel like screams
because it's like multiple like
teenagers and like ghost face and it
could be one of them that is ghost face
it sets up like a twist better yeah
because they really like doing that
where like a friday the 13th would be
like oh you know who they should
revive an old franchise let them make
the next entry in the faculty remember
the faculty
all the faculty is an old old movie
where it's like a weird horror alien
[ __ ] is it aliens horror [ __ ] happening
in a school
and like the teachers have become like
really weird it's such a good movie you
did that it's one of just like nice
movies
yeah
that's the same josh
elijah woods yeah like bringing back a
classic robert patrick yeah wow
he's like one of the teachers i think oh
okay um or even like someone points out
uh tryland points out episodic x-files
like you could give them x-files i mean
like i've been saying for years i've
always wanted like a telltale x-files
game so yeah just give it to them yeah
but also
in this movie so yeah uh aliens
something like cory should definitely or
whatever super cool
definitely get uh usher in their next
game they haven't done aliens yet so
that would be something new for them i
guess so like if they that would be a
good like tonal shift as well yeah um
i thought you meant like the problem
and i was like [ __ ] no leave alien
alone please everyone i would rather
have a glimpse
yeah i would rather i would rather have
supermaster take an attempt at the alien
franchise than another over-the-shoulder
or like
isometric chewa game in that franchise
which is exactly what we keep getting so
yeah um
my actual like breathing as opposed to
of course
um so let's move on unless anyone else
has anything to like make it the thing
that would be awesome
there is already a the thing game and
it's very it's pretty cool it's very
good you should play that i think it's
like my favorite i think it's on pc so
you can play on the steam deck maybe
all
anyone else want to bring anything up
before we move on i've put a couple of
in
oh okay okay let's let's speed through
these ones so then we can get to the
actual feature one that we came up with
um
this comes from the smoking man x uh
chris pereira no id x-files fan
which is not relevant to this but no
x-files leica x-files leica um yeah we
have a it's mika and chris pereira in a
group chat about the x-files and it's
called the x-pests
which is great
um
uh he says uh deadline headline just now
chris pratt says his super mario bros
voice is unlike anything you've heard in
the mario world oh
this is gonna be racist it's gonna be
racist i don't i don't think it's
i don't think it's going to be racist
the whole thing i think i think he's
just going to sound like chris pratt oh
he's just going to do it i think he's
just going to do his normal voice i
think they're going to they're going to
like take his voice and make it
squeakier
like someone's like a slider and just
like inches it up just a little bit i am
curious to see if there's gonna be any
backlash when people finally hear this
stuff and there'll be a change.org thing
like we saw with sonic oh sure no chance
yeah you don't think so i don't think so
i mean i think i think even if there is
a normal voice i think even if there is
they wouldn't change anything again you
know we've been working on this movie
long enough like too bad
yeah i think it's going to be a bog
standing voice and i'm just like
i don't know batman says an auto-tuned
t-pain mario i did think about
it
he just sings all of his lines if there
isn't a gag where he collects the star
and does the like the super mario the
superstar mario version where he's
flashing and in that version his voice
is just autotuned then they failed like
this
i also like the phrasing unlike anything
you've heard in the mario world because
it's like what have we heard just like
wow like we've had mario
any of the games that are like smash
that are like rpg or luigi's mansion
the film's co-producer defended pratt's
casting and vowed that his voice work is
phenomenal
pratt echoed
melodandry's
sentiment telling variety that mario's
voice has been
updated oh no that's not good
there's no way the trailer this comes
out
into oblivion there is more i worked
really closely with the directors and
trying out a few things
and landed on something that i'm really
proud of and can't wait for people to
see and hear it's an animated voiceover
narrative it's not a live-action movie
i'm not going to be wearing a plumber
suit running all over and providing a
voice for an animated character and it
is updated and uh unlike anything you've
heard in the mountains he's just gonna
put on a new york voice
[Applause]
no he's going to do the tony soprano
voice yeah
that's right he's going to constantly
talk about gabagool
or he's going to be who's going to be
poorly or chrissy yeah if this movie
doesn't end by teasing wario like
absolute waste of time isn't wario
supposed to be in it didn't they
announce the voices
is it isn't it like charlie day or
something no no no no
um oh no no is wario in it yeah i think
so brogan
i need wario to be like the thanos of
this you know this like where they keep
teasing him
and then he's like fine i will do it
myself
and like goes inside
slowly yellow hat yeah
because jack black is bowser makes sense
keegan michael key as toad
yeah how he has potential i hope he does
and then it doesn't have a um it doesn't
have wario oh okay is where you're not
in it i'm telling you he needs to be the
post credit he needs to be like
he's they need they build up to him they
build up to him the same way that he
becomes the fan off and he just wants to
snap as well i mean like he makes
everything he's like i want to get all
the infinity stones or whatever
equivalent is so i can make all of
everyone's money all the different
mushroom items yeah he makes everyone's
money disappear by clicking
well that's what activates you should
have gone for the head
everyone's money goes away that's what
activates the superstar power yeah it is
right
well i'll tell you what i saw i can
write a better marriage
whatever they have already done you
thought's about to make this video
i saw jurassic world dominion with chris
pratt and it was him with chris pratt
yeah he went with chris pratt no but
he's in that movie and that was one of
the worst movies i've seen in theaters
in a very long time so i have no faith
i mean i didn't have much faith in chris
pratt anyway but like good lord that
movie is like three hours long it's
boring as hell the enemies aren't even
dinosaurs it's like locusts or some [ __ ]
like what the cues
yeah
pretty much i mean that would be more
interesting to be honest that would be
more interesting
like it is it is
yeah i think like terrible jurassic park
as a franchise now this is gonna make a
lot of people like absolutely boil some
piss but like that franchise needs to be
just like put to bed for a while for a
really long time i would say it would be
extinct there should have never been
jurassic world in all of the uh the
world was fine i was
do you
want jurassic park's legacy to be like
you know some of the movies were just
the first one is good in in in the
context of the rest of them like if i if
someone was like you gotta watch one of
these i'd watch that first one happily
well sure the first one's great i mean i
think world is better than like three
yeah
like like if they had stopped it world i
would have been like that's fine it's
okay right yeah but unfortunately in the
same way like to get over yeah alien or
whatever it's the same way like if
they'd stopped at like uh
force awakens i've been like oh okay
yeah cool cool star wars is cool um i
enjoy you you should never you should
never say those words in that order i
enjoyed seeing the same film again but
with a different cast
bob jones did say spoilers i think he
was referring to me saying like the
locust thing about uh uh
jurassic world
like that is introduced very early like
i'm not gonna spoil this movie i don't
think it's good i don't think you should
see it but like don't they bring back
the old uh they do and that's probably
some of the more interesting stuff but
like it's i'm seeing a jurassic park
movie i just want to see dinosaurs
and i'm like both those dinosaurs should
bite his arms off come on
as well right right he's like trying to
control the first one where he's like
trying to make blue and blue yeah and
like it's like oh my god
it's not watch this great i remember it
we watched it it's like the jurassic
park movies they just steadily get worse
over time squirrel just gets worse over
time watch it all together during e
no it was pre-e3 remember yeah oh yeah
the whole company they sent everyone to
watch the first one
oh i don't remember that
you were definitely
um but yeah i i don't know that's i i
feel like it would just be a normal
voice yes um like what voice would it be
it's just gonna be hey i'm mario
i don't know i feel like that's been
done no
i think that's exactly how it's gonna be
oh me
that's yoshi
that's just yoshi
they just swapped their voices
um
so let's get the to the uh the feature
of someone um biozo biozel says what
should we what should people buy from
the steam summer sale what's in the
seams
it's hard because steam keeps crashing
oh here we go
you should buy hollow knight doesn't
matter if it's on sale hey look there's
an article on the front of gamespot.com
which is best steam summer sale 2022
gaming holidays i did see i did see the
mass effect uh legendary edition had
naught percent off uh accidentally they
listed it
is that free somewhere right now it's on
amazon i think amazon's given it for
free oh wow i'll quickly read off the uh
the the things there's a couple of these
from the article that we put up um
written by multiple people uh disco
elysium do maternal final fantasy vii
remake integrate um death loop is on
sale monsanto rise red dead two cuphead
the sims sakura oh strange horticulture
yeah
uh dragon age the series is on sale
starts on sale good one uh into the
breaches on sale and that's a good one
because they just announced some new
content for that um sims expansion packs
are on sale this is not a drill for some
reason they're in steam yeah because the
zero is five dollars
oh the easily easy sell yeah life is
range two is cheap um
the sims 4 is 4.99 there's some good
deals there there you go
just uh
get them but play them on steam deck i'm
going to text georgia and cali right now
just so you know okay we have a group we
have a group i mean
if she was able to buy it and not have
to ever open origin again she'd she'd be
like i will gladly spend the 5 20 bucks
so i just don't have to open it up
quarry does that as well like you launch
it on steam and it's like guess what did
you know there's a 2k launcher oh yeah
yeah yeah
what is this [ __ ]
also the other day i realized that
tinyteen's wonderland is out
yeah
quite some time
i edited the review of it and i like
someone someone sent me an email being
like hey tiny tina's uh is coming to
steam i was like what is it out what the
[ __ ] yeah oh cause did it did it go to
it was epic epic first i thought
when did it come out did it come out a
year ago
it came out right after eldon ray
think this borderlands 3 oh yeah way too
much money right it made a lot of money
wasn't tiny tina pretty good actually
like i heard that that game expansion
was actually kind of good i think just
no one talked about it because the
expansion was really good i'm not sure
that you can make an entire game off of
that okay expansion i i played like half
of the game and it was fine it was okay
i did not find it as
obnoxious as borderlands 3's writing
which isn't hard it's not right
it's pretty bad but i also was like
yeah this is just kind of more
borderlands three and i already put like
50 hours in a borland stream
they just took those mechanics and just
put it into a new
world like how hard is that so james
james carl our very own james clark says
tony tina is aggressively fine
all right folks let's get into the big
feature for the week which i came up
with
minutes before we started and here's the
here's the concept
okay we're going to make enemies here
um and chat get involved
um
the idea is
you have to remove one game from
existence
okay but the objective is
to do the most damage to the industry as
possible and the butterfly effect of you
removing that game has to be huge
okay i already have one to make
to make this more challenging should we
have like a cut off here because like if
you say a game in like 2005 it will
automatically have a bigger effect than
the one that released in like 2015. true
i think you got to really i don't know i
feel
i feel like i feel like the interesting
part of this is to think about what
happens as a knock-on effect
um and the the the thing that we're
going to do is we're going to remove the
ones that are like
oh we're doing this for evil right now
obviously foundational like you can't
say pong it will maybe take out like
doom damn the chatters
yeah
okay so yeah um we'll go one by one
uh john luke looks like this is
eager because i know i know who this is
going to upset um
pub g
oh
you gotta get rid of that yeah what's
the justification on what is the
knock-on effect well
uh
say goodbye to all battle royale games
yeah including fortnite including
fortnite dies
fortnite dead fortnite is just this
weird game that like epic put out and
everyone forgot game spot goes bankrupt
in 2018
made that one video about how that mode
wasn't very good and then everyone
forgot about the game like that's the
whole thing that's interesting giving
fortnite a second chance
so obviously you're like okay well
that's crazy because then you don't have
things like warzone you don't have apex
legends yeah you don't have a paper
here's why that i don't care about that
no no no
more importantly you don't have hype
escape
of course
no you don't you don't have apex legends
aggressively
which means
respawn didn't have a win
they might not exist anymore oh
shut them down which means we don't get
jedi falling we
but also we might not have like as many
companies being open to cross play
but that's true because fortnight no one
took on apple and google no one wore it
no one fights uh google and apple
yeah tim sweeney
yeah tim sweeney doesn't have his popeye
cup um also uh what we're talking about
uh
vince zampella then doesn't
become like a senior executive at ea
it's true yeah which has a knock-on
impact on
battlefield yeah battlefield potentially
dies
as a result of that there's there's a
lot of first-person battle pass
oh yeah the first one is
i think live service games as a whole
aren't as popular without the battle
royale i mean
yeah like they'll still exist but i
don't think i think fortnite is like you
can point to that game as like the
reason why we have
like all of these uh like live events
why we have like all these like uh like
crossover skins like you look at call of
duty and they have like godzilla and
like you know king kong in their game
that's because of fortnite that's
because fortnite put john wick in their
game and it was really big and then
they're like let's just keep doing that
forever was john wick the first one it
was one of the first years
yeah
but then that means that has impact on
the careers of ariana grande it has
impacts on the careers of trump
uh
christopher nolan's movie yeah we
wouldn't have been able to watch
if we get rid of pubg we also don't get
to a point where we get callisto
protocol
so that's the truth
because that game got green lit by being
so is that something that you want to do
oh to get rid of fortnite yeah i'll do
it
it's worth it
summer game fest has proven we're
getting so many dead spaces like this so
it's like we can lose one
wow
that's a good one mm-hmm that is a big
one i was going to pick fortnite but
pubg is the better yeah but do you think
the question is now is doing that do you
think it's a net positive or a net
negative
have you done enough evil i think it's a
net positive because i gotta be real i
the whole like current landscape of of
it's it's not even like battle pass like
uh battle royale because i feel like
battle royale is kind of tapered off and
battle pass stuff is like i actually
kind of think that sort of makes sense
as a monetization thing it's better than
like because it replaced uh loot boxes
and blue boxes were like trash it's a
better setup
but i don't like this like
weird world we live in where everything
has to be like this insane like licensed
crossover like i kind of hate that [ __ ]
um like i i'm just like why
are you putting king kong in the like
world war ii call of duty game like like
i just i'm not into that kind of stuff i
know that some people really like and
that's fine but like for me i'm like
yeah
i don't like that
yeah i'm kind of the same way like i
think it's great people who love
fortnite for being like this absolute
just like
melting pot of everything sure is like
great great for you but i just find it
very strange to see like
lightsaber people fighting
spiderman yeah while batman is dancing
just fortnite did it but then it's
fortnite's popular so everyone's trying
to do that and it's just so obnoxious
what was that song that was that meme
video that came out which one yeah
fortnite
it's a flash is a flash song about
everyone fighting everything
ultimate showdown of ultimate yeah
history that is what fortnite is now yes
like because this is like it was just
like a song that worked in every
franchising character fighting each
other yeah but that's what this game is
now is it a kid going 10 kills on the
board right now that's not a kid though
is it not it's a great woman
oh yeah it's pretending to be a kid
yes
i thought that was well known no i had
no idea
chug jug with you
by leviathan
we've destroyed okay so i really like me
i feel like
damage wise
if we use defcon levels wait no it says
leviathan is a canadian youtuber known
for his fortnight based song parodies
he's 16.
i don't think so so i which song am i
thinking of then no i thought it was
that one because i remember like i heard
it was just an older kid like not liking
not like a grown-up
lady i heard it was like a woman that's
what i heard maybe i'm wrong maybe we're
getting i'm gonna do something
um
yeah i feel like that's a death contour
moment sure
um
i feel like that's pretty big damage
it's big damage yeah so
at the end we'll decide who's done the
most damage
who wants to go next i um
i feel like the
easiest answer for first person shooters
would be something like doom or
wolfenstein because then that genre as a
whole just doesn't take off but a harder
one that i think also does the [ __ ] tone
damage is halo 2 because then you do not
popularize like online multiplayer on
consoles and
like
that's that basically kills call of duty
yeah yeah
you could go halo 1 and just like the
xbox is just dead oh yeah there's no
killer app
i just figured halo 2 because it affects
like beyond just what xbox is well
taking out halo one you remove an entire
yeah like console generator it's just
that big two instead of the big three so
you wanna go halo two halo one
keeping in mind well if i get rid of
halo one i might i'm technically getting
rid of halo 2 so yes i'll just do halo 1
then so
that means like jordan by doing that
eliminates pretty eliminates xbox as a
whole yeah xbox is gone no game pass
yeah oh my god you killed it i mean you
killed the game
xbox wouldn't have needed something to
save it from its last lack of first
party games so like the fusion frenzy
wasn't going to save the xbox we
wouldn't get the bottom of an avatar
shoe no no no you can't handle the one
version okay
doritos crash course never happens
happy easter eggs wait does another
console
rise in xbox's place or is it just
nintendo and playstation like now up to
the dream world who knows yeah i guess
like does the dream cast like stick
around no definitely not
yeah
i guess no like they're
like xbox basically bought their way
into this competition with halo the
thing is the interesting thing is like
also does that impact
bethesda pretty big way yeah yeah xbox
hasn't bought any of the studios
because they aligned themselves with the
west and developed platforms mass
effects mass effect yeah
that's yeah that's a bunch basically the
majority of modern western rpgs are now
gone because jordan or they're just
stuck on pc and they just never come to
congress
yeah yeah because bioware had a huge
presence on the original xbox like
because they were like please witcher
like we'll help you make an xbox port
yeah that's huge i mean like also like
how many
there's like a bunch of studios that
don't make it like undead labs probably
doesn't yeah exist state of decay was
much uh ninja theory ninja theory
well they were doing okay but they were
doing okay but like um yeah yeah the
investment they wouldn't be able to grow
the coalition wouldn't exist oh yeah
yeah it wasn't existing wait if gears
doesn't exist well does that mean does
that garage does not get big enough and
fortnite doesn't happen oh
oh my god that's true also like gary
jones probably doesn't get as popular as
no he was donnie darko he's fine
that's true no but mad world really
helped no that was tony darko though
yeah but after donnie darko like was it
i think like the gears thing is what
really propelled him way further i don't
think i don't think people as i bet you
if you put them side by side gears had
more of an impact than donnie
no you do not understand how huge is
that trailer
but it's like synonymous with one of
them i feel like donnie darko is still
quite a like cult movie whereas gears is
like i could i will tell you as a kid i
hadn't i hadn't seen donnie darko i had
no idea it was from that movie i knew
but i knew it was from the gears yeah i
think that's that's the case for a lot
of people all those all those xbox kids
i say like john luke i was also like oh
yeah from gears
yeah hey we don't have that gears
trailer we don't have like all those
other like trailers that we're trying to
mimic it we don't get that dead island
what happens to the career of what's his
name who voiced the big phil uh marcus
phoenix and john dimaggio
so how many studios just get [ __ ]
without xbox around the coalition's gone
it doesn't exist three four three three
three is gone um who knows what happened
to bungie yeah destiny would that even
be a thing well bungie is probably still
makes games the monkeys don't make sales
dead and apple now rules all of gaming
the sad you know what the monkey's poor
situation is
uh accessibility in games is not as good
yeah yeah so that's true that's true
yeah because microsoft is pushing yeah
and like all the all the kind of other
stuff that they do to make make games
more accessible
are you happy about that this was the
point of the game
he's right because that that excludes a
lot of people away from gaming damage is
that whole like indie movement we had
with xbox arcade like just doesn't
remember like when xbox
they really pushed uh like indie games
what did they call that
xbox from arcade
oh yeah because that first one was only
on xbox oh my god
it was a trash version oh okay bayonetta
probably doesn't come back which means
nintendo doesn't pick it up later yeah
which means it doesn't get a rare ten
out of ten for gamespot for bayonetta
dude it probably just doesn't exist
which means platinum might not be around
because bayonet was pretty big yeah but
then we don't get ones fall so like it's
a positive yeah
damn
um i've killed fortnite that's really
all that matters
is that what this thought experiment is
it's like how can you have 60 degrees oh
yeah it's like 60 degrees
uh yeah that's a big one uh who wants to
go next
i i have i have one that i think i might
need help working through but i guess
that's why people like i got two i'm
trying to decide between should i just
say both and then we can figure out
which ones we also have a great one in
the chat there's something like that i
was gonna say there's a good one in the
chat there's one in the chat that i saw
that's really good i think we should
we'll see we'll
save that for the end like
one of them is final fantasy vii oh wow
the other one that i was thinking was
super smash bros i feel like you should
go with final missing seven probably
yeah yeah
smash brothers those games still exist
those games still exist
but like if anything ross yeah i think
that we get seven
if anything you're cleaning up the
industry by making playstation
right now to jake's point if you take
out smash you
lose you lose people like me who are
like oh i played smash because i
recognized like mario and yoshi but i
didn't know
like samus and then i go to play metroid
that's like yeah smash helps get people
i feel like i guess it was more of a
personal thing for me because like most
of these games that i'm familiar with on
nintendo's end were characters in smash
like the reason i played earthbound was
because of you know ness and yeah and
like you're saying metroid but uh i do
think sevens probably yeah so that's
[ __ ]
my guy how can we like kill fortnite
kill fortnite without sevens exist how
do you kill phones if you're killing
seven are you is the implication that
like they don't make any more final
fantasies like i think it was more i was
thinking like i guess
just becomes the new seven kills
like final fantasy in the west right
like well yeah i feel like seven is the
one that
never makes
doesn't get involved so does that kill
the playstation one does that get
kingdom hearts no playstation one still
has yeah it still has a bunch of other
major games it's all crash bandicoot
it's got like a bunch of now you're
right
but i feel like the jrpg takes a massive
i feel like this is a lot of people are
saying it does nothing well i feel like
taking out final fantasy vii isn't one
of those things where it's like oh we
start losing all these things it's more
like there are so many people in our
industry that like oh i'm only a
journalist i'm only a developer i'm only
this because i played final fantasy vii
i fell in love with games and so you
lose a lot of people who might have
fallen in love with games at a very
crucial time square enix doesn't become
popular enough to write square doesn't
become popular enough to rival enix
which means they
either
dragon quest becomes at that point they
were still just square yeah okay
soft yeah at that point either dragon
quest becomes dominant in the jrp genre
or i think
dragon quest also dies because they
needed to merge yeah to carry on
existing which means like they never
bought
they never bought tomb raider or they
never bought all those games which means
who knows what even happened to that
stuff legacy of kane
the chat wants to go with the timeline
that with seven gone eight just becomes
the news i don't think that works
because because eight only gets was
built based off
of seven that's right because like the
steam order
i don't know what they call it team punk
or whatever it is like the the nomura
vibe doesn't exist
yeah go forward
this is an insidious [ __ ] jake like
this like
if it's a little more subtle i think
it continues nine becomes the next one
because it's like classically final
fantasy and i think okay this has
implications though like we can't even
dare guess
i don't think i don't think final
fantasy lives with nine becoming the
next one i don't think it lives on tv no
no no 14. yeah because your parts still
happen without i know kingdom
god
the idea of kingdom hearts of branching
these very different franchises might
have been an early inspiration for
fortnight and so
there we go that's what i'm talking
about
yeah so i think that you kill off a
bunch of
major yeah jrpgs major franchises and i
i feel like
like you're just killing people who like
grew up well you're not killing them but
yeah here's the thing or like they they
take different inspiration for their
first video game that they make very
very big chance that if you kill off
final fantasy 7 you kill off undertale
oh [ __ ] so somewhere michael he started
crying i mean he's in this yeah he said
he literally said [ __ ] yo
to the 14th to the 14th
um i think undertale goes away because
dragon quest obviously um is impacted i
guess earthbound is the main one
inspired game yeah
there's a whole lot of final fantasy vii
inspired games that goes
away advent children goes away which
impacts the movie industry
he's really in only a positive way
his career is like fully dead david
boreanaz never voices squall in
kingdom hearts
hayden panettiere is not as popular
and that means she's not in until dawn
maybe yeah that's that's her in point so
i feel like that's big damage that is
big damage
but is it a net positive do you think um
i think the the effects aren't as quite
as
big but the effects are generally
negative i think
except for getting rid of kings i think
you've done it
yeah maybe you've done
not a major amount you've done a very
specific amount of like damage yeah you
heard a lot of people like michael
specifically
um
jordan do you want to go next uh yeah
uh
i think a very easy one you just kill
off yeah you called it right away yeah
you kill off demon souls
we don't get anything take out demon
cells like
and then basically that kills off
like it kills off so many souls like you
killed all night
kills hollow knight you kill you kill
vardy
wow a lot of
kill off myself
yeah but you kill off uh arcades
our friends don't have a career now yeah
wow um yeah like yeah they pivoted to
just resident evil content and you know
what happened what are all those indie
developers you know what happens instead
the industry is still dominated by
third-person over-the-shoulder shooters
the brown ones yeah the brown ones where
sticky cover that is the predominant way
of maybe interacting with games still i
think maybe um yeah but you like
miyazaki doesn't make any any games you
are getting rid of the art should games
be have an easy mode discourse though
yeah okay i clean up twitter
there's like i also take out uh stranger
paradise which yeah i mean
a gastroparesis
uh but yeah there's multiple that is a
studio i think like that also impacts
what caterpillar games
um
and and probably impacts like
famitsu in a way
how much does that just affect like
japan japan as an industry like it
starts to take a bit of a hit there was
there was that period in the mid 2000s
where i felt like japan's like hold on
the video game industry was really
slipping yeah and i think
well here specifically not in japan
right like it felt like like they
weren't prioritizing it but i feel like
uh
like square as well but also like from
software is a huge reason why like yeah
japan is still like top of the game when
it comes to games like you can't beat
them because you got [ __ ] elden ring
like yeah but those that also kind of
impacts playstation 5 like because
blue point making demon souls remake
that was like the major game perhaps not
like as pivotal as halo but like i feel
like the playstation 5 struggles a bit
hard more i mean you might just
absolutely destroy bandai namco
but yeah
definitely
so all those anime
yeah like japan is code vane cold
everyone's everyone's morning code vein
i'm sure
yeah wait wait well in the uk at least
bandai um published the witcher
oh yeah oh yeah
atlas is also kind of hurt by it because
they published demon souls in a bunch of
places and it made them uh hella bank
that's true um so which means personas
impacted by that we could kill i think
like that was that was atlas usa that
was a different different george harris
loses an excuse to focus on his books
and yeah
i did like look over in slack and
apparently he is working on that [ __ ]
jon snow sequel series i was like
george she read the book
someone points out gundam is probably
not living uh a bunch of naruto games
are gone never that's probably not as
popular as it is now
um you hate to see it so i feel like all
my all my tales games are gone
i feel like you guys are giving from
software a little too much credit no
from software killing off bandai namco
oh
there's because like i was one of those
people and i'm i'm not speaking for
everyone but like there's a bunch of
people like me who are like oh i didn't
get into anime i went to a friend's
house they had an anime game i played
and i'm like oh now i'm going to go home
and actually watch the show
it's like about and anime games get
better that's what i think happens
because like oh because bandai namco
does it because
it doesn't like factory yeah sure
bananco doesn't connect with cyber
connect too and make the same game for
every franchise a lot of people are
saying like we're not saying they would
kill bandai namco saying it would affect
bandai namco greatly because i mean like
there was a period where dark souls was
pretty much everything banda namco had
sure yeah yeah but they would probably
like geek out a living yeah
yeah i i just think i think that's your
point in japan it would just be a
different landscape for them we'd have a
different bandai namco yeah yeah they
would have never changed
i'm not
would we even have bandai namco uh north
america because they have uh
um
we probably wouldn't have prepared to
try as a phrase
get good wouldn't be a phrase
but like the ones who are like doing
similar games like oh it's like demon
souls and dark souls where like they
hide their lore we wouldn't have hired
dave dewey yeah we wouldn't hold dave
uh wow friendships have been ruined yeah
you're happy yeah oh yeah i'm loving it
it's great
uh lucy so i have two different options
one of which is
the legend of zelda breath of the wild
the other one oh you took out the ring
the other one
says the guy who just killed dog
the other one is um assassin's creed oh
because if we didn't get assassin's
creed if you think about the for a while
though it created so much positivity but
then if you if you didn't have
assassin's creed think about the
pervasive way every open world game has
tried to emulate the ubisoft oh does it
kill the ubisoft over the kills it kills
the ubisoft
i consider that only a good thing yeah
that's probably true like for a while
lucy is really evil and then for a while
then it's like oh and now you're doing a
good thing you're like
here's a weird monkey's paw
if
open world games just didn't become
popular and didn't become oversaturated
or people wanted to like make them
better does breath of the wild happen
yeah it's true well the reason so the
reason i picked breath of the wild is
because i was like how do i how do i
take out nintendo and i was like well
nintendo's gonna have time yeah but
let's think like two hundred at a time
i didn't want to go all the way back to
like keep it for sure but like if you
think about when nintendo was in the wii
u and like the switch was like safe you
take out one of these sports whatever
you do
if if the switch didn't launch with
breath of the wild it would have
launched with like once
wii sports is if you take out
struggling from gamecube yeah i think if
you take out wii sports you you kill
nintendo yeah yeah we supposed to kill
nintendo completely so are you going
with assassins i want to go with
assassins just because you changed the
landscape of everything yeah you don't
get which we wouldn't get uh the [ __ ]
movie you want to get
but you probably also wouldn't get the
which was which was first prince of
persia movie or the the prince of
persian movies yeah yeah so it might
still be so you just wrote me assassin's
creed 2 is the thing that really got me
into video games we might have gotten
more prince of persia games yeah yeah
maybe i would have played that i mean
i don't think we're getting signs of
time any time
[Music]
a joke never appears in metal gear solid
4 yeah
[Music]
yeah watch dogs doesn't exist
um
once again hyper escape probably i was
going to say far cry might exist just
because
i would be like back to how it was yeah
it would be like um the far cry 2 yeah
that's better
no no if they had evolved far cry 2 and
went in that direction instead of like
what if we make it more like assassin's
creed with like checklists everywhere
way better i feel like way better
collegian is a is a an argument against
that
no but i'm saying
like i think i think there is something
to be said about like evolving
too like there's an alternate pathway i
could have gone that would have been way
more interesting ubisoft looked at all
their franchise and they're like how can
we make all of them like assassins
that's crazy yeah
it doesn't
is successful in buying them out maybe
we would have gotten another splinter
cell game though um
my other option i was toying with gta 3.
wow you just kill rock
open world games
gta online is done red dead is done
polly's done
throughout the month
so there's like a it changes the
landscape of like ratings hot coffee
doesn't happen yeah which changes the
industry
um you don't have uh rockstar gamers
with danielle radcliffe on the bbc
oh god
um
that's wild but you don't have the new
dre album
why you might do but
damn's like i'll live
it's broadly fine yeah um that is a good
one though assassin's creed is a good
one
less icons on the map
it's a really good modern was the one
from chat so there's one in chat that
was really good that was half-life
oh no i was looking at the other chat
one
uh world of warcraft oh i wasn't even i
was looking at the one after that which
was candy crush which like really helped
mobile gaming like get into
the thing with half-life that they
pointed out though was that steam
wouldn't exist you know and like that
would have been too specific i think
yeah half-life specifically that would
just kill steam entirely because the
reason why
people adopted steam that kills
counter-strike which kills esports in a
big way well no counter-strike was still
around wait for half-life 2
yeah but like i don't think
uh
i don't think it gets as big
oh no no no no no no you're right like
cs go doesn't become like yeah csgo
doesn't become well like uh source
doesn't become a thing sure and like
making it free doesn't become a thing
which means like competitive stuff
doesn't work and there's like it might
have impact on delta as well yeah
i mean if you have like one you're not
only killing because you you would kill
obviously um counter-strike but you're
killing like all the multiplayer mod
maps you're killing like team fortress
you're killing if you kill blue shift
gearbox is gone
which means borderlands never happens
all right
really if you're just killing steam
though like you're just killing this as
well
but just killing steam like one place
that unifies so many games on one
platform on pc
that would also kill battle royale too
right because that was it's just gabe
newell in his office with one knife just
one guy yeah
did you kill him you killed titanfall
that was on that was on oh yeah oh yeah
um
gary's mod you also kill off every steam
like though so like origin is gone
the every other launcher is gone because
no one tries it i mean i think it it
would eventually happen it would just be
like who knows what it would look like
yeah they probably would have tried to
tackle it the way that people do it on
consoles like oh we need something like
that's a console but on the pc maybe
maybe the microsoft store became a big
thing
yeah
that's a big one and we also have a good
one
okay now we have to decide who did the
most damage i think it's pretty obvious
who did the most yeah absolutely
yeah
yeah killing pubg
yeah that was uh although that destroys
the modern games
i feel like he has a slightly better
answer because it just is like it's a
more modern you should do a pull-up
i'm doing a poll right now i'm doing
this
oh that's a good idea
because i did the thing where it's like
oh the further like if we had said like
pokemon or doom or mortal kombat like
those have larger effects just because
they're older i said halo yeah which is
you should two thousand you should put
all the options in
um
final fantasy 7
and then assassin's creed and then
assassin's creed
and then the chat one was uh oh i can
only do five there's only five yeah
we'll leave it at that yeah oh
interesting canon shadow says without
thief the entire immersive sim genre
disappears maybe not
thief but if you kill um altima if i say
there was something yeah
you kill you kill immersive sins which
means you kill
which means arcane uh
so you kill
if you kill oblivion you don't get horse
armor that's oh
it doesn't exist
i would have done it
ea would still actually timeline skyrim
doesn't exist
uh
okay
got some votes coming in on uh if you if
you're watching on twitch yeah oh looks
like uh halo and pub g oh no pogba yeah
i'm really vying for it i got one
tomorrow we got one yeah no i got one
i'm good that's fine i should have
changed mine to wii sports damn it
yeah we sports we sports really [ __ ]
yeah
yeah
that's me and mo retired
that's iwata retired reggie never
happens like i never got so many people
oh my god a bunch of metroid also just
motion control
which means which means the connect
probably connect doesn't happen
which doesn't happen gaming never gets
to mainstream tv which means as an as
like a landscape we're still the kids in
the basement oh yeah yeah your grandma's
not playing yeah a bunch of tv screen
samsung is probably out of business
because they don't have to repair tv
screens
that's massive damage uh we've got a
winner uh with 47 of the votes it's
george jordan
i think that that's that's i hope you're
proud of yourself
you know i am the super villain
all right folks that brings to a close
the first ever gamespot after dark
podcast live if you are in the chat
thank you for hanging out if you haven't
already please do follow the twitch um
channel twitch.tv slash gamespot if you
were listening through podcast services
i was of course joking you are very much
appreciated
he says at the end
if you are listening just go to twitch
and you know
follow us there we want to try and grow
this as an upper a place for us to do
the live podcast as well it's fun as we
prove like interacting with chat
um and we're hoping this will be the
future of gamespot after dark but we
need you to kind of get involved and
help us out with that by hitting
um follow and like sharing it and
telling people about it that would be
really really cool um also you know if
you can go to the podcast services and
rate and review us there that would be
awesome oh yeah tryland also says uh the
games for youtube is 10k away from five
million yeah let's go so getting close
if you could throw us a sub we are going
to be archiving these on youtube as well
do we want to talk about the t-shirt oh
yeah oh yeah
yeah so if you don't know we went to um
uh summer games fest and wore this
t-shirt key
3
which limited limited edition which
proved to be quite popular
and there was much demand for it to be
sold
um and um we weren't sure whether we
were going to be able to do it but we
spoke to the powers that be
and it looks like
the key three t-shirt is going to be put
up for sale um
it is
very affordable we had a conversation
about the pricing
we did our absolute best to drive the
price as low as possible we're not 100
sure what it's going to be but i think
it's going to be like 25 ish yeah
um we are obviously obviously that money
is going to gamespot and it's going to
be
we're a corporate the red vendor is a
corporation and it wants to make some
money but
it's not a crazy margin we're trying to
get people who want this t-shirt out for
as cheap as possible um it's gonna
function on a pre-order basis because
obviously we're not at a stage where
people are aware our parent company can
commit to just making these as it
happens so it's gonna be a pre-order
system where you
register your interest and once you
reach a certain amount that's when it
starts printing yeah um
i think you'll pay up front yeah yeah
you can you pay up front and then you'll
get informed you'll get informed it's
coming now yeah um so it's
it's it's like all about board it's all
it's all going to be cool like i can
talk about the tea we can talk about the
t-shirt itself like it's good quality
like it's it's decent quality um the
design is obviously fun
it commemorates it kind of commemorates
um i don't know if we're using the same
manufacturer but i know that the the
ones that we
the shop that we use did our previous
year's t-shirts for e3 and they're all
good quality yeah um
so this is the kind of start of it like
a lot of people showed interest in the
key three t-shirts so you can buy that
if it's successful we'll start moving
into providing other cool t-shirts like
people have already talked about doing
an after dark t-shirt can i say
by the way huge shout out to donna dan
who used to uh work here at gamespot
yeah bomb um but like came back to help
freelance uh our new logo design yeah
yeah and huge shout out to um
the previous designer my my brain my
culvert brain is breaking our intern
um miranda
yes
the previous logo that did us like well
for so long shout out to her but yeah
like dan auer did our current logo a new
logo for the live part of it and it's
really cool
um if it gets you know if we can if this
you know t-shirt run is successful we'll
start working with
um designers to make cool t-shirts
yeah in the same way that giant bomb
does and yeah
hopefully we'll grow from there
so yeah keep an eye out keep an eye out
on um
the podcast and gamespot.com and various
other places we'll tweet about it once a
bit it was available um and once it's
available to uh
buy and get yourself a key three t-shirt
it's a novelty get jeff keeley has one
he does he was very excited to have one
oh he was i wasn't sure because you were
like you just gave a thumbs up
he was like where's my t-shirt okay and
i was like bro you gave me a thumbs up
but he very much wanted it and like when
i saw him later he was like hell yeah he
took the t-shirt
so jeff keeley has one uh when the show
returns next year you better believe
we're gonna be calling it key three i've
seen other podcasters and other
publications starting to call it key
three and you know that we came up with
that [ __ ] so yeah get behind it and um
yeah uh there you go the first bit of
merchandise for
i guess this podcast i guess yeah yeah
yeah yeah so we'll see you again next
week um timing remains
to be uh uh confirmed just because we're
trying to stay out of the way of
voicemail dump truck we don't want to
cannibalize um
yeah the viewership on giant bomb
because they are our friends and
colleagues and we work with them and we
also want to
listen and watch voicemail dump truck
instead of you know yeah so um so yeah
we'll figure it out you know maybe maybe
three maybe four or five yeah we're
thinking later um but we'll find a good
time yeah you know we'll start we'll
experiment with things and see how it
goes
keep you updated on the discord yes if
you're not ready join the discord it's
growing it's a really nice community and
then now that we're live you better
believe like we'll have more guests and
we'll have we've done a five-person
podcast now and it works
you know heim's here all the time jake
is back
and we're gonna probably bring in people
from other places as well we used to
have folks from like kind of funny show
up and
it feels good to be back in the studio
and we're also live now so i think a lot
of people are gonna be up for coming in
i took the blessing all the time and
he's like let's do another podcast and
we'll get folks in so
honestly i just can't tell you how nice
it is to
do these conversations not through zoom
zoom i am oh sorry no you go first
yeah exactly yeah exactly
um so yeah
about to be a stronger podcast um so
we'll see you again next week
um take care everyone
bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]